one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast for a very special
Hump Day episode because I am in Studio
which like she's always in studio this
girl she doesn't work at the studio but
she's in the studio with kind of like a
crazy special guest
it's Jax yeah that's right Jackson
Claude in studio haven't been in studio
weeks in a few weeks it's good to be
back it's so amazing to have you here
sis I'm so grateful to be here love
podcasting with you love podcasting
together in person but let's be but
let's be real we're here for a purpose
we are here for a purpose I wasn't just
gonna break my bed rest for nothing no
for something worth it for something
worth it and this is for sure worth it
because I have an announcement to make
secret project reveal secret project
reveal I don't make a lot of
announcements you don't you could you
don't even like to use the word
announcement like you take that word you
don't take it lightly yeah
this so this is an announcement it's an
announcement to end all announcements I
think so I would say I think it's the
biggest announcement no it's not the
biggest announcement I ever made because
I feel like that would be like
pregnancies yeah I guess but it's up
there it's up no it's it's seriously up
there it's a fellow labor of love
because I have written a children's book
you guys you're not [__] ready the
camper and the counselor if you're
listening as a podcast highly suggest
coming to YouTube because I have a copy
of the book and I will be showing you
some of the illustrations it's the
cutest book it comes out on October 10th
but it is available for pre-order now
wherever you pre-order your books Amazon
Target Barnes Noble Indie bound Walmart
and I think we all I think we all
learned the importance of pre-order when
I was promoting my book it's so
important to support authors in their
pre-order phase so it's so nice you know
you spend the money now a few months
from now you get a little gift right it
just shows up at your door we were just
talking about this on the redheads how
pre-ordering is but like with books to
like it just shows up on your Kindle and
your Kindle it just shows up at your
door you don't have to like set a
reminder okay her book comes out October
10th so I would highly recommend
pre-ordering it and I would also really
appreciate it it would mean a lot to me
uh this is the camera in the counselor
and of course it is inspired by my story
of the camera and the counselor that has
been living rent free in my head since
2018. if you've been a toaster for a
while you know the shtick I Am the
camper Margot is the counselor and which
is like so disgusting because I'm
sitting right here it's so disgusting
towards turdy
it should be called the dirty and the
charity the turd and the charity do the
sequel the turd in the dirty I like that
I like it too so let's talk about the
ins well tell me you know I want to give
it anyway spoilers but what is the
premise of the book and you know who is
this book for because I have an idea in
my head who the book is perfect for so
that's a great question who is this book
for it's listed as ages one to nine
because I this is Harry's favorite book
like it is a great book for the newborn
face because it Rhymes I was not going
to try the children's book that didn't
rhyme because I don't read children's
books that don't rhyme no I don't know
[__] with children's books I don't mind
like what are you doing if you ain't
rhyming it's no fun to read a children's
book to your child that does not rhyme
couldn't agree more and when I sit down
to read a book to one of the kids like I
literally am cardi B like I'm so on
point I'm obsessed with iambic
pentameter so much so I went over your
book a few times to make sure that the I
am big pantameter was on point we went
over every verse over and over again
like clapping it out making sure it hit
the right notes and it does it's so good
you guys like good luck getting through
it without crying it is the sweetest
thing if you went to Camp like you know
how as like a young person Camp is so
magical and the book totally captures
the magic of camp like if you have like
even the more like the remotest like
warmest feelings towards camp like
you're gonna die if you went to Camp if
you have a kid going to Camp I feel like
it addresses that whole you know
homesickness thing it's ages one to nine
because you can read it to your newborn
baby or toddler but then also at eight
years old kids start going to camp for
the first time and it's a really great
prep book for a kid who's going to camp
for the first time I mean I went to camp
at six right I went to camp at eight
which is the standard age snitch went to
camp at five yeah she had like her whole
family yeah all the sisters were there
so like what's she gonna spend the
summer at home right come on over to
camp and oh my God we just loved Camp if
you listen to the show you know we're
like obsessed with Camp so this is like
such a natural extension and I think we
can officially remove my irrelevant book
from the from the the acrylic placard
and place yours I think that we can this
will be a ceremonial changing of the
book guard oh my God it kind of goes
with our aesthetic but I know I'm also
just gonna have to like take it home
every night because it's truly Harry's
favorite book no and if you like our
cameras aren't that high def but if you
like really zoomed in you would see like
the pages Harry's like tearing yeah
chewing on ripped out one of the birds
there's all these like he loves birds
and there's birds throughout the book
and he took one as a souvenir can I can
I read like the first page yeah I was
gonna read like up until not be making
this about me
I mean you could but
um let me just read the first page it's
so cute like you could read the first
page and I'll read the second page okay
the camper and the counselor by Jackie
ashray illustrated by Paulina karmazova
who did the most amazing job like these
I'll show you also show everyone my
favorite page okay fine okay fair it's
the first day of camp my bags are
tightly packed my duffel trunk and
pillow are all neatly stacked we bump
and we bounce up curves bends and Hills
the windy Camp roads give me goosebumps
and chills
dad you want to read the second one sure
it's so camper it's so camber we're here
I yell as we pull into the drive we've
made it to Camp I'm so glad to arrive
yeah and we all haven't memorized at
this point it's 32 Pages which you know
and you can add it to your Goodreads you
could I'm looking forward you're it's on
Goodreads I will be adding that to my
yearly book count I'm looking forward to
adding it to mine this is Claudia's
favorite page which this one let me say
yes oh my God so the camper is of course
redhead yeah yeah
um I I didn't really like see a camper
who like really looked like me it was
probably like the chubby one running in
the at the back of the pack that was
probably me
um but the red-headed camper is so cute
she has green eyes she literally looks
like Jax curly hair and on this page
she's kind of she's ease past her
homesickness and she doesn't even
realize that she's so far from home
because she's having such an amazing
time at Camp she's reflecting on the
good time she's reflecting on the good
times she's in nature she's with the
leaves and here is I forget I don't know
what Paige this is but she's just like
living her best life and I couldn't be
more obsessed with this page like you
really need to see it in person which is
why you should pre-order it
um the camper and the counselor.com yeah
you really need to experience it in
person it is this book is do you want to
put it here uh yeah maybe I'll show my
favorite picture yeah what is my thing I
mean they all have my heart I think they
all are amazing Pages oh actually you
know what I think my favorite page is
like the last page and I don't want to
spoil the ending oh we're at the ending
you guys I'm like seriously good luck
not crying it's so [__] cute no I
used to read the book in all its
different iterations to Harry like
throughout the first year of his life
because I wrote the first draft when I
was nine months pregnant with Harry so
over a year ago and honestly the book
just wrote itself because the story has
been living in my head yeah you all know
I've been LARPing as camper and
counselor and I've always dreamed of it
being a children's book but I was in no
rush to like write it especially before
I became a mom but then when I was
pregnant and I was quarantined and had
all this time on my hands and I was like
let me take a stab at it no I remember
the first time I heard it via FaceTime
chills yeah the first time I like read
it well so first I took a stab at it I
wrote my first draft the words poured
out of me it's changed so much since
then but you know the the general story
is the same but like the first time I
read it over Harry's crib just like
based on notes on my phone he was
probably like one week old yeah
um he loved it he I'm sorry and raptured
no the thing is Harry's got taste it
really is his favorite book right now
I'm not even exaggerating and that warms
mama's heart it's the cutest thing the
camper and the counselor.com it's so
good like it's perfect gift of course if
there's a mom in your life if you are
not a mom or you're an auntie it's
perfect for that if there's like a
toaster in your life who's having a baby
it's a perfect baby shower gift if
you're a godmother if you're an uncle if
you're a dad if you're a mom if you're a
sister you're an auntie like whatever
it is it's a great gift and the best
part is that you don't have to be a
toaster to enjoy the story there's no
inside jokes in there it's for kids for
everyone yeah it's for everyone but the
toasters will know like the origin story
where it comes from and how much it
means to me it is the sweetest thing I'm
obsessed mazalto welcome to the uh
author Club author Club so this is like
a podcast hosted by two authors it's a
very literary podcast it really is it
actually has been for a while yeah but
now it's two authors it's only like 2019
me could see us now I know should we
change the name of the podcast to two
authors one cup
no two authors one book
even though we have two books but yeah
I think it's I like my better
okay even though I'm an author who for
the life of her cannot pronounce
submersible
what's why do you need to pronounce it
that's what it's called The Submarine
that's oh some mercy play Sub sub yeah
everyone's saying sub and it's because
they don't know because it's not a
submarine it's a submersible okay
everybody I said yesterday submersible
and then I was like summer sibling
summer
wait what would you say submersible
submersible that's so easy yeah
submersible but I feel like they're
making it extra complicated it's a
submarine and for what it's a submarine
what what we're gonna talk about that we
are but you can get my book for
pre-order Link in my bio we'll post it
everywhere today on Amazon just search
me Jackie ashrae it's called the camper
and the counselor and it is my pride and
joy I've worked so so hard on it
especially in the last few months like
that's when everything really revved
page layouts illustrations all the
illustrations and like putting together
the book happened in like the last two
months
um but all the writing like happened
first when I was pregnant and then it
was like shopped around not really and
then um in the fall I did all the
writing editing so it's so good it's
really been a labor of love it's a book
full of love it's a book full of love
it's a book that radiates love and you
know what it's so wholesome like it the
message is just fun fun good times the
power a female friendship and mentorship
the power of female friendship and
mentorship yes and just having like good
old-fashioned fun that's it no it's so
true like getting outside being with
your daughter really is like some of
these children's books I'm like what is
the message like the one that I was
reading
um I'm not gonna put any on blast like
it's like is this about death oh is this
a metaphor for death no I do think some
children's books are meant to help with
like difficult topics of course no but
there are some that are like what is
this about even when we were doing the
Cat in the Hat recap people were like
it's a statement against working mothers
come again because the kids are home
alone with the Goldfish and this is the
Ruckus that goes on honestly I could see
that I don't know if that's how Zeus
meant it yeah I don't know if that has
that's how Sue sees it it says sees it
but yeah some of these books I I finish
them like I read them Terry I'm like
what did we learn what did we learn what
were we supposed to learn so what are we
going to learn from the camper and the
counselor that you have to trust the
process you have to bloom where you're
planted you have to bloom where you were
planted and it will all work out and
you'll be better off for it it's about a
leap of faith it's about a leap of faith
I love that so pre-order now I'll be
reminding you up until October don't
worry don't worry I feel like they're
worried you shouldn't you shouldn't if
you forget today slips your mind there's
always tomorrow tomorrow I'll tell Ben
he has to promote Ben's read it Ben's
read it Bennett like the way we all like
the the iambic pentameter like takes
over and you get in you're like I'm so
glad to arrived like yeah you become a
nut a nut job yeah you do and I will be
doing
um readings throughout the promotional
process you know little spoilers here
and there so people can really kind of
get the voice down once the book arrives
works for me that's kind of like where
Maverick came from remember you just
like said give me a page any page give
me a word any word and then we heard
about the beauty of Maverick pre-order
kimberlycouncilor.com you know who loves
this book Maverick actually I haven't
spoken to him in quite a while things
have been kind of tense
ever since you opened up yeah like open
debating for him and he didn't respond
ever hear from him never heard a word
hmm
but like I wouldn't even know how to
contact him I don't know if he would
know how to contact me
people know how to contact you yeah I
guess yeah you're easy to find well I'm
wide open Maverick
except for Ben yeah
um well we've got a great show today we
do have a great Wednesday which means
dear toasters the stories they came
together in a Flash you guys this is the
sort of week we were just getting cocky
and like saying oh we're too good for
the past I like this is the sort of week
where the Fast Five fuels me I was
genuinely devastated devastated
yesterday that I was not on the show
because three of the five stories I felt
so deeply passionate about of course one
we will still be talking about today
because it is the story it's a
developing story and it's Global News
and every day people are invested and
that is the Titanic and the fact that
there's Titanic news and I wasn't here
like it's devastated well you know what
I don't know if there could have been a
better person no gustasi's so obsessed
she's so obsessed it was as if it was me
sitting yeah yeah a pregnant yep Titanic
file yeah no it was perfect and she gave
some great Insight on Vanderpump Rules
she was a great if you haven't listened
to the episode highly recommend she was
great yeah she was great I really
enjoyed it did you get to I didn't talk
to you yesterday sorry I didn't talk to
you yesterday because I was in Boston
doing a spritz mean greet which was a
little sigue to everyone came and I
wanted to tell you about the thing that
happened to me in the middle of the
night but I actually wanted you to hear
it on the podcast first were you dying
uh yes but like the fact that you
couldn't take any responsibility for
your role what the [__] did I do besides
literally get up to piss no I know but
like
I don't know it's just like that just
doesn't happen to people you know no but
let's go back my role Your Role first of
all if you see a figure in the door like
that's your husband you know his shape
by the way that that of course but
rationale and logic when you're in like
a a panic situation never persevere it's
always always screaming oh my God not
you I'm blaming you're victim blaming
because I just like literally you'll be
sitting here and like the door literally
the door opens here and you can't see
and you know you can't see past the
light and you scream every time I'm very
easily scared yes so when somebody opens
a door I'll literally my heart will stop
I'll be like but this was not like a it
was like I know
invalidating my entire experience I'm
not I'm not but like it took two like
and also you posed a question who is it
scarier for
I don't know obviously it's scary for
you you think there's someone in your
house
but for Ben he's like stumbling through
the dark and just hears a scream oh my
God I I literally hate you I'm so glad
you weren't here yesterday match because
you would have like invalidated my
entire my entire experience scary
regardless and what's so crazy obviously
is that of all hours of the night the
two of you got up at the same exact time
well I have to imagine when I got up to
pee it like rustled Ben a little bit and
then he was like yeah I should pee yeah
there's been a few nights where I've
gotten up to pee recently and it's also
like the same time like if Zach falls
asleep on the couch like it's the exact
same time like I get into bed and then
he comes in I'm like did you hear me
maybe
and that like alerted him like oh it
should be better like I don't make I
don't make a peep because I'm sharing a
room with Harry right so I literally
don't make a peep Maybe
so that's the coincidence no but I I
don't mean ten dollar date your feelings
it was crazy it is it was crazy you but
you guys are crazy but we're not we're
just like simple human beings trying to
get through life you're crazy people we
love to scream
I am very easily like scared and like
I'm the perfect person like you hide
behind a door and you like oh boo yeah I
will have to go to the hospital like I'm
and it's not I don't put on a front like
I I wish I wasn't like I probably three
times a day does my heart stop yeah and
like how blessed are you that you don't
have any creaky floors I know that would
have alerted you that's really like why
people always like when are you moving
to Florida like I can't live in a house
houses make so many sounds I would be up
all night but you would hear if someone
was coming into the bathroom
maybe yeah maybe I would have more than
one bathroom you know yeah you do have
more than one bathroom I know but my
guest bathroom I cleaned out my closet
and I had all these bags for donation
and I shoved them in the guest bathroom
because I didn't want them like
cluttering at my house so the guest
bathroom I got rid of them yesterday but
the guest bathroom has been out of
commission which is why me and Ben were
sharing a toilet got it and because you
didn't turn a light on that too yeah and
what was that about
in the middle of the night that that's
rude oh I like I'm peeing so much in the
middle of the night now I close the door
behind me and I I turn the light up a
little bit actually we have a light in
our bathroom through the dark we have a
light in our bathroom that just lights
up the floor fancy it is really fancy
but like whatever I'm just peeing in the
middle of the night I'm not even washing
my hands it'll be 10 seconds like I
don't flush in the middle of the night
either I haven't been because I don't
want to wake up Bruno who had to bark
and wake up Harry yeah like it's also
just an insensitive thing to do it's a
chain reaction 100 I don't know but if
the person's in rem they're not going to
hear the flush he wouldn't hear the
flush you just
um I don't know I don't want to risk it
I'll do it in the morning it's a problem
for tomorrow may yeah that's what I've
been doing too
um all right I feel like we should dive
in because we have a lot to get into
today
the Kurds that are you know back on
their [__] like last week when we
were just like podcasting till no end we
also have deer toasters today we
actually have a submission I feel like
we're always talking about
mothers-in-laws we have a submission
from the mother-in-law it's interesting
to get a perspective she's a real
sweetie I'm so interested to get it yeah
it'll be good so I think we should dive
in because I am like feeling you're a
future um yeah I'm a future toxic
mother-in-law 100 proud and proud so
without further Ado here are the past
five stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
mattress firm mattress firm's mattress
matcher is a unique quiz to help you
find the best mattress for your needs
from the convenience of your phone or
computer so they're going to tailor the
results of their quiz uh for your
desired mattress size Comfort level
sleep positions sleep disruptors and
more sleep is so personal mattresses are
so personal me and Ben sleep in the same
bed but we have such different needs and
our mattress is for Mattress Firm
actually we got it
at the beginning maybe four years ago
it's really still in amazing condition I
love Mattress Firm the common sleep
disruptor is like snoring allergies
tossing and turning temperature pain
acid reflux of course sleeping in the
same bed as your partner the mattress
matcher will recommend a high quality
mattress from America's top brands like
Tempur-Pedic Stearns and Foster purple
nectar sleepies Serta and they will find
the one that's right for you they're
more than just mattresses too at
Mattress Firm they have bedding
accessories from your sleep needs like
pillows sheets mattress protectors
adjustable bases in-store their sleep
experts can match you to the right
pillow depending on your sleep style and
find the right material and height for
your needs with their 120 night trial
you have 120 sleeps to make sure your
new mattress and pillow is the perfect
fit for you because you know what
there's nothing worse than like getting
a new mattress and like sleeping on it
for the first night and just like not
being the best but you're kind of stuck
with it not with Mattress Firm they give
you 120 nights that's three months 120
four months wow four months to figure it
out and if you're not happy with it they
will take it back which is really
fabulous summer is here and Mattress
Firm has a few really great sales a year
and one of them is the July 4th sale it
is a place to find a high quality
mattress and bedding accessory at every
price point it's a sale you've been
waiting for to upgrade your quality to
Quality sleep the right mattress matters
Mattress Firm will find Yours shop in
store or online at mattressfirm.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by the perfect bar the original
refrigerated protein bar that you know
we love if you haven't heard perfect bar
just launched a new line of protein bars
called perfect bar layers and you know
what some would say it's layered I would
yeah I think you would perfect bar
layers are a new line of crispy protein
bars that are stacked with three
delicious flavors and packed with whole
food nutrition they're made with a
crispy base of peanut butter and cashew
butter they're layered with dark
chocolate or 100 real fruit and then
they're sprinkled with toasted
gluten-free oats
Yum Yum Yum delicioso they're packed
with up to 11 grams of protein they come
in two delicious flavors crispy peanut
butter and chocolate and crispy peanut
butter and Berry basically like a
healthy peanut butter and jelly they're
made with only whole food ingredients
it's their classic blend of 20 organic
superfoods they contain no artificial
preservatives making them
storable in the fridge which makes a ton
of sense like it's so fresh where do you
keep your freshest things Jax the fridge
right so like now you have all these
crusty old bars sitting in the cabinet
no not perfect bar they go in the fridge
they are stacked and packed and if you
aren't convinced already they are also
non-GMO project verified gluten-free soy
free kosher and low GI the best part is
that you can now find them in the
refrigerated section at Targets
Nationwide perfect bar knows that it'll
be Love At First Bite so they're
offering you a chance to try their new
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text and upload a picture of your
receipt from your local grocery store
and they'll reimburse you for the cost
of one bar directly into your venmo or
PayPal account all you have to do is go
to perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking thank you
Claudia welcome our first story the big
story of the week critical equipment has
arrived in the last chance effort to
save the Titanic sub passengers search
Crews desperately racing against time to
save the passengers on the same Titanic
bound sub had three U.S Air Force planes
deliver critical equipment and tools to
Canada late Tuesday and what was
described as the last chance to rescue
them the massive C-17 glow Masters which
are believed to have been flown from New
Jersey and North Carolina landed late
Tuesday in Newfoundland land
Newfoundland
oh
I don't know
it's giving Dak tuned
where they were met by several flatbed
trucks the cargo was frantically placed
onto trucks which made their way with a
police escort to the waiting Horizon
Arctic a Canadian Supply ship that said
wait
sale
oh my God I think I saw them
what do you need last night what did you
see
oh my God we were driving home from
Boston I did my meet and greet in Boston
last night and about I think we were
somewhere in Connecticut and they said
that it drove from no and they were
going the opposite way they flew to
Canada oh and then drove to the ship is
it possible that I saw them
um
no okay I don't think so because on the
other side of I-95 literally there was
standstill traffic and when we finally
reached like what there was like four
enormous trucks holding up like the
entire
um
I don't know what it was but we were
like all so confused trying to figure
out what it was
crazy you don't think that was it I mean
it could have been and there was there
were police escorting it
I mean you were going to Boston so these
ones when I was driving home from Boston
but they were going the other way on the
I-95 right and like it is it's about
like 300 miles off the coast of
Newfoundland but 900 miles off the coast
of Cape Cod so maybe they were going to
the cape I'm telling you I might have
seen it you might have seen yeah sure
something wow crazy maybe I was like a
part of the rescue efforts let's just
say that yeah yeah yeah
um so they went to the supply ship and
made the joy Voyage to the middle of the
sea to try and find the sub that's
missing this so that they said this is
the last kick at it this is the last
chance there's no other chance than this
ROV underwater vehicle
to find the um the sub but also I saw
this morning that they're hearing some
sounds using Sonar that sounds like
banging so if the sub is still intact
and the passengers are still alive they
might be like banging to to what to make
sounds so The Radars would pick up sound
yeah they wouldn't be banging to try and
get out because getting out doesn't help
them no they would be banging to be
found there's a bunch of different
theories floating around to not help
them no not it kills them yeah
um there are a bunch of different
theories one of them is that like at
some point on the Voyage to the Titanic
the whole thing imploded yes because it
now where all this footage is coming out
of like the inside they made all these
videos before it's extremely poorly made
it's like you know put together with
like a remote control from a PlayStation
and a piece of duct tape like it's not a
fancy military grade piece of equipment
it didn't meet a lot of the regulations
that like
um
it they would have had it me but this is
private um yeah it's not like a
government or a military travel so the
people who sign the waivers and I think
did you see that um Simpsons producer he
had written a story that he did this
trip oh my God and the waiver and even
the first page said death three times
damn yeah but he talked about like his
experience going down and how it's like
so different for everyone like when they
went they kind of got like lost on the
sea floor we're like looking for the
Titan not lost in a bad way but they
couldn't find the Titanic by the time
they finally got to the Titanic they
only got to see like the anchor in the
hole because they had to go back up they
were out of time oh damn um but then the
next day a new trip went down and they
got to see the whole thing so this has
been done many times not like so many
but it's been done successfully yes okay
interesting um and I don't really
understand because when me and Sassy
yesterday were looking at pictures of
the submersible there was like a little
window there's just one window it's not
like a thing made of glass so you can't
see see even though you're in this thing
you're when you actually get to the
Titanic they're showing you the wreckage
on a screen
well can you look out the window I'm
sure I'm sure but like they're showing
you on like I this just doesn't seem
like a good investment
yeah because you know I could do it for
free I go on YouTube and watch it on a
screen too of course but if you can see
it out the window and you're like there
sure that's cool especially if you're
like a thrill seeking adventurer right
and perhaps like uh
history buff right one of the people
whose rumored to be on the submarine
this time is like a French
Titanic expert got it there is also a um
someone who's on the submersible their I
think nephew or something stepson
stepson is Making Waves because he
posted on social media last night that
you know the search is underway for his
uh stepfather and he has decided to
spend that evening at the Blink 182
concert he posted on social media at the
Blink 182 concert I know it seems odd
like odd timing for me to be here but my
family would want this they know how
music can help me during a difficult
time
and um no it was crazy it was like by
the way go to go off like go to concert
I'm not going to judge anyone for what
they do during a difficult time but like
you like genuinely like you don't need
to post everything you're doing on
social media like if I had heard this
like if you told me like oh you know I
happen to know that guy's son and he
went to the concert I wouldn't think
it's weird but the posting on social
media is weird yeah
like that's what makes it weird yeah and
obviously everyone felt the same because
it's like headlights news right what did
you write exactly okay pull it up it was
just like a very
um
just we didn't need to know this it
might be distasteful being here but my
family would want me to be at the app
link 182 show as it's my favorite band
and music helps me in difficult times
okay like
thanks
they're so like at the end of the day
this is such a sad story and all like
all the experts who are weighing in on
this are saying like it's relatively
hopeless that these people it's like a
thousand chance that they'll be found
and found alive now we're like under 24
hours of oxygen left right and you know
that's assuming like nothing's gone
terribly wrong inside like somebody
hasn't become like I said yesterday like
Lord of the Flies you know people can
get crazy when they think they're about
to die
um
so it's all very
um unlikely that this will end happily
and it's so sad
but now like all the information about
this company has come out Ocean Gate and
it's like it's a it's an amazing that
this company hasn't been shut down that
people have successfully gone and come
back up like that this is the first time
you know something so bad has happened
because it's like
it's hella unsafe yeah
but I think that when people sign up for
this like they they do know what that
there's a risk because we're also like
hearing from other Thrill Seekers who
have pulled out of this based on like
what they saw yeah but I don't really
think that like one of these wealthy
people would bring their 19 year old son
if they like really thought there was a
good chance they weren't coming back
like yeah there's like a risk every time
you go bungee jumping sure but this is
like another level yeah this is another
level so I don't think anyone would like
bring their child if they like really
thought it was so dangerous
yeah I mean like there was an article
written in 28 there was like a
whistleblower at the company being like
this is so unsafe and he was fired yeah
because they just like wanna get down
there right like regulations and getting
up to all these different codes we take
years yeah right right if they wanted to
like go about it the real way yeah but
those codes are in place for a reason
right
so crazy I feel as though like
everyone's talking about this it's just
so crazy that it's all about the Titanic
no it's the Titanic claiming more lives
I know and it's just like the Titanic is
like cursed of course but
it's just like this magnet like people
and I'm I'm I am magnetized magnetized
by it but like the way that people are
obsessed you know you're so right nice
and I'm talking about me yeah
it's a crazy thing if somebody had
offered you a seat on this thing never
for free like no money oh my God I'm not
I'm not you're not a Seeker you're not
at all that would that does nothing for
me like oh my God never no I'm like
what's the opposite of a thrill seeker
I'm like a chill Seeker literally like I
well I've never been but like um
bungee jumping no I've never done like
the craziest thing I ever did was like
the plane no no I've never skydiving
like the CR like for me like when I
think about the craziest things I've
done in my life it's like jumping off of
like a really high Rock when I was in
the bvis and it was like the scariest
thing and it was quite literally 10 feet
oh yeah I jumped off like a big boat
once yeah yeah that was like pretty
that's crazy yeah and um we did the leap
of faith in the Bahamas yeah there's
like a really tall water slide which is
completely safe and like fully regulated
it's for kids it's for kids yeah I'm not
a thrill seeker I avoid thrill at all
costs I gotta like going in Fast Cars
nope except you drive with your husband
I don't think I'm ever gonna get it in
the car again with him I don't think you
should we got back from Boston Boston is
a minimum four hour drive right we got
home from Boston in two hours and 45
minutes last night and we only had one
like near-death experience and honestly
in Ben's depends it was not his fault we
were in the left lane and all of a
sudden and we're going fast because
we're on a highway in the left lane all
there's no signs all of a sudden these
cones appear and it's like the left lane
is closed so it's a have to merge to the
right lane into the right of us was this
enormous truck we had no idea our lane
was ending Ben handled it he got we were
fine
but yeah we almost had two but you know
what I was in bed my event my event was
at seven
ended at seven excuse me
I was in-home showered in my bed
watching shrinking at 10 o'clock that's
crazy and I'm I'm happy for you in that
instance but
he's out of control no I know
I we drove back with him from One
Republic over a year ago One Republic
remember we went um a year ago at uh
Homedale no it's so funny I remember
going I don't remember being there I
thought it was like a sister's night no
he was there he drove us yes you know
what I do remember we got home so fast
and it was horrible yeah but like the
thing is and I will say about Ben
because I'm in no rush like oh Ben oh
yeah that's Ben's thing he's like he
watches the ways if it says you know
estimated time arrival 9 30. he will not
rest until the ETA goes down minute by
minute by minute till like 9 30 we'll
get there at nine that's it's just not
and he's not rushing towards anything
but I just do want to say in Ben's
defense he's a crazy driver he's not a
bad driver and he's really not an unsafe
driver he's just a very fast he's just a
very fast driver and I just don't think
we need to be going that fast no and
like with our new car which we'll
hopefully be picking out today or
tomorrow
um I'm only driving with you yeah no I'm
definitely worried about it because like
all right it's Ben's parents car like
sure do your worst oh right now but like
this is my name on the insurance like no
we will be driving the speed limit at
first great yeah and so crazy on our way
on our drive to Boston it's basically
one long drive it's like not like you
know a million directions you're just on
this one road for like 100 miles like
the entire time we were stuck behind a
car that is the car we're picking up
same color and everything and it's a
kind of an off the beaten path color
it's not just like white or black how do
you tell people what car you're getting
no I'm saving it for the Vlog oh okay
except there were girls at the meet and
greet yesterday they're like did you
drive your new car and I was telling
them because like they came all the way
which one did you just which one do you
wind up going with oh good good good
yeah it was you know it was more but
more is more yeah like it's my first car
like I and I just want to say like the
way I'm so influenced in terms of car
purchasing by The Real Housewives like I
wanted a car that could be seen on the
Real Housewives and that I've seen other
househives drive like I know that's
weird but like the car that I got I feel
like most of the women in Atlanta Drive
oh that's interesting that didn't
influence my decision at all except once
we decided not to get this one car
then on Kardashians Kendall drove to
um her horseback riding lesson it's a
it's a Land Rover Defender we thought
about it like we were almost gonna get
it and it's cool but like it's just a
little too cool for me you know Kendall
she's like so different yeah like
extreme and it's really it reminds me of
like Prince Philip like are you guys
hunting it's a hunting car what are you
doing but then like I decided not to get
it and then of course Kendall shows up
driving it
I think that's okay I think it's okay
too if Chloe had shown up I would have
been really devastated yeah
well we're we should keep you updated on
the submersible
hopefully that these bang like hopefully
so if they run out of oxygen obviously
they will all pass away do they continue
um searching for like the remains I
think so it's not it's now uh it's not a
recovery Mission it's not it's not a
rescue mission it's not a recovery yes I
think they will continue searching for a
period of time yeah
um but it's crazy it's like everyone's
coming together talking about this who
pays for the rescue
like which country you mean and like
from what funds well they're in
international waters correct yeah so
it's I know you know Canada's in there
America's in there France I think is in
there everybody's it's all hands on deck
and also these people are from all over
they're not only Americans
Pakistan Arab Emirates yeah
um so it's a global Affair I think maybe
the UN gets involved I don't know right
but it's like but the but the taxpayers
pay for yeah their country's involvement
right I don't know just curious that's a
good question I'm just curious but then
also I'm sure if there wasn't these
rescue missions like the families these
people are a billionaires like families
they'll be fine they'll be fine but it's
just curious yeah just just kind of a
cure this cat
are you ready for our next story yes
are you I am but I was just seeing
pictures of the equipment on the trucks
and I wanted I was like should I show it
to you to see if that's what you said
okay
it's not a great
it's not like it's like cargo
where's the truck no yeah it was
obviously
we have to talk about one more thing
what and no this doesn't help me
that dumois got a tip that everyone's
okay yeah Jamal got a tip basically
saying like I know people who are on the
crew like everyone's been found and
they're all alive like God willing but I
I don't even think I don't think Dumont
is like you know has that level of
intelligence yeah only like if that were
true I pray I pray but only like the
president has that love you know what I
mean like maybe the president wrote into
Dubois I could see it happening I know
I'm keeping uh just checking what do you
mean like do you like refresh yeah
refreshing you know I don't think
there's any news right now but of course
I think once we rap something will
happen but if like if if tomorrow's tip
is true then it should be forthcoming
yes that's true if that's a big if yeah
are you ready for our next story some
other global news from yesterday yeah
the Louis Vuitton men's fashion show
star shadow in Paris with star study
Jay-Z and Beyonce stepped out together
Kim Zendaya Riri and ASAP yes Gwen
Stefani
I don't know if I would include her in
that like Kirsten Kristen Davis
okay so Hilo
oh sorry these are just people alive
just people who are alive yeah literally
turning the jumper wasn't there okay
that didn't sound right like everyone
what about that Gwen Stefan no okay yeah
Gwen Stefani Kristen Davis and Nina
dobrevi just didn't like fit they were
just like this is an article it starts
with the Louis Vuitton show but then
it's like what other celebrities are
doing no the Louis Vuitton Joe was in
where was it Paris yeah
um it was star-studded everyone's like
quaking over the video of Zendaya like
walking over like all these benches to
get to Jay-Z and Beyonce and say hi and
they give like warm hugs law roach was
with her also giving hugs
um it was lost sitting I don't know it
was before the show started so they
weren't like at their seats they were
just like chilling by the water I'm sure
he was sitting front row with Cindy
that's not gonna happen yeah and they
were like wearing like coordinating
outfits I was I'm not worried yeah
um Kim was there
wearing like a spandex bra on leggings
and no like
you know at some point when you when you
like you know obviously work and
represent a brand like you just wear
what they tell you to wear but I think
Kim has enough influence Kim it's a rack
yes we've seen it before
um and I just don't understand this like
athleisure style I like the world's
biggest fashion show of of the day like
what are you doing no it was it's a it's
not a good outfit Rihanna and ASAP
looked amazing in these like matching
coord light blue monogram like obsessed
uh Beyonce wore this like big yellow
item like everyone was really doing the
most and Kim's wearing leggings and like
I just don't get a it's not even about
the fact that she's like wearing
leggings like if it looks amazing then
it looked it would look amazing but it
just it really did not it's leggings in
a bra leggings and a bra on a big fanny
pack a bigger fanny pack oh yeah and
heels yeah
I just remember personally like a
leggings and heels girl
no not not really like outside of
pregnancy like where you would have to
be wearing leggings you know what I mean
yeah that's fair but um
but athleisure I hear I hear what you're
saying yeah so it was fabulous and I
loved all the content coming out of it
especially from Rihanna looked so I love
the way she just dresses her bump and
she just bumps it out you know I loved
that it was a gorgeous day in Paris it
was and everyone really showed up and
showed out I think including Gwen
Stefani there was a Pharrell
very cool and it was men's and it was
men's I feel like the men's Louis
Vuitton show was always like a bigger
deal in the women's
because men's for so long was Virgil
that's why and all the celebrities went
for Virgil and now I think they like
still go for Virgil and like Pharrell
now is yeah collabing very cool love to
see it but the Louis Vuitton women's is
always like very cool very fashion and
yeah but it's not like Beyonce Kim yeah
I mean Beyonce doesn't just like go to
things no especially she's on tour I was
speaking of tourist Taylor announced
yesterday like the biggest world tour of
all time like I never saw so many
International dates and she's going to
like you know every some places feel
like natural you know like London
Manchester but like there were places on
there I was like wow so Random like you
know Chile I think no chili she's not
going to end the president wrote her a
letter asking oh that's why okay wait oh
not me taking down the whole set hold on
let me read you all the dates and
there's like multiple she's setting
records of course she's playing the
Melbourne or Sydney Cricket Arena which
is seats a hundred thousand people geez
yeah it's really major okay let me read
the cities the Chilean fans are mad but
also the Filipino fans are really mad so
they were doing that thing at the mall
exactly
four in Mexico three in Argentina two in
Brazil three in Brazil three in a
different part of Brazil
four in Tokyo two in Melbourne three in
Sydney three in Singapore two in Paris
one in Stockholm one in Lisbon one in
Madrid one in Lyon France two in
Edinburgh
Edinburgh Edinburgh Edinburgh Edinboro
in the UK
um two in Liverpool
one in Cardiff
two in London two in Dublin two in
Amsterdam one in Zurich one in Milan one
in gelser kirchen Germany one in Hamburg
Germany one in Munich Germany one in
Warsaw Poland one in Vienna and then two
more in London at Wembley so yeah
it's going to Warsaw yeah that's what I
meant like really kind of Niche do you
think she'll do like March of the living
like I I hope our Queen will take some
time while she's in Germany and Poland
to learn about their history and you
know what went down there I do I
actually do hope so but I do I feel like
busy she's busy but I feel like when you
go like abroad like you're always doing
stuff like yeah as an American yeah are
they all like really close dates to each
other she's just going like hopping from
Germany to Warsaw I already exited it
out yeah I don't know but it looks like
it's you know pretty back to back
that's a lot no it's crazy no I'm
exhausted for her people didn't know if
she was gonna do but like I think
everybody hoped and that's like the
biggest tour I've ever heard of yeah and
like it's not just the Classic places
but of course Paris of course London of
course Tokyo of course Australia but
Edinburgh Manchester all those random
places in Germany yeah like as an
American pop star that's
that's major like I feel like Harry
Styles does a lot of international but
he he's not American you know yeah and
it's not like he did a huge American
tour he just sat up at MSG and waited
for people to show up yeah and same with
Staple Center yeah
so it's very interesting Queen just like
kind of doing Queen [__] being the
biggest star in the world yeah I feel
like there were some Taylor news like
she did something she went out to dinner
Gigi
no that wasn't it
maybe it was like a song or something
well there's rumors that the lover
Deluxe album is coming but like P I have
to get off Swift Twitter Cruel Summer
it's a single yeah and there is a music
video I believe I don't know if she's
announced that yet and she was supposed
to make it a single in 2020 but then
like with condom she didn't but you know
what it's good because the song is
having like a Renaissance because it's
the opening song of the era's tour it's
like doing like 100 million streams a
day and she's like that's never happened
to me where a song from four years ago
is just like popping off so I couldn't
do it then but I can do it now and I'm
glad because like lover really is so
good we were talking about this but like
what people know from lover people who
are not like big swifties who just
listen to the radio they know me they
know you need to calm down does she do
me at the Eris tour no but it was me was
a single you need to calm down was a
single lover is good and the Archer
those were both singles too but like
they're really not reflective of like
what the album holds yeah so I think in
a lot of ways like lover didn't reach
its potential until now because people
didn't look into it because what was
representing it was not yeah me and you
need to come down are like yeah tough
tough songs so for people to actually
hear you know Cruel Summer Death By A
Thousand Cuts Like Miss Americana those
are like the real true pop bangers of
the album for people to now hear Cruel
Summer on the radio I think they'll be
surprised yeah and I'm happy I love that
I love that too
oh my bladder
um I don't like have to pee but it's
just like you know your bladder is like
saying hey Jax I'm here yeah yeah yeah
it's it's fun it's fun are you ready for
our next story yeah unless you want to
pause and pee no no no no no I don't no
Zoey 102 trailer drop for the movie Zoe
101 okay you guys I rolled to the back
of my head okay I was ready for that
because I hate reboots I hate oh I don't
even hate reboots but like literally who
asked for this nobody besides Jamie Lynn
who asked for this nobody really asked
for this but I watched the trailer do
you watch a little trailer I was
surprised by how
good of a premise it is and like I feel
like it could stand alone is just a
movie outside of being a reboot outside
of being a reboot it's based the plot is
that um Quinn and Logan are getting
married okay Zoe is like been single and
struggling Chase is I think he brings
like a date to the wedding and Zoe like
brings a fake date but like it's really
about like her and Chase like
reconnecting at their High School
Friend's Wedding which would be a movie
No it's it's a fine premise but like the
way I don't like wait up at night I
think that look the cast of Zoe 101
thinks that the fans of their previous
show wait up every night being like
what's what are they gonna drop today
like I don't think anybody cares like
honestly no I don't think anybody cares
really today but like Zoe 101 will
always they've left us wanting more
obviously like Jamie Lynn exited the
show again we were not done with it like
it was such a great it was an amazing
show
um so they think that like this is the
next step and as far as other like
reboot things that we've seen I just
actually feel like this is a decent idea
it just looks like a cute rom-com that's
based on the characters of Zoe 101. cute
really I was ready to like be eye roll
to the back my head I thought it was you
know gonna be like Zoe is a teacher at
PSA and she's like
yes Seth no sad sad it was not this is
like a whole separate entity like you
could watch this movie and have no idea
what Zoey 101 is and it's just like for
sure two High School like let's just
saying it's falling in love like the way
the cast on social media and even like
the People magazine exclusive is like
the fans have been waiting we haven't I
just want to say as a fan of Zoe 101 we
have not been waiting I don't think
about Zoey 101 their shows that I think
about it like that I say oh my God I
need them to get back together like I
need some sort of like there are shows
Joey one one is just not one of those
shows for me and I just feel like the
way it's so blown up everyone and I feel
like over the last couple of years
they've literally like said a million
times like it's happening and it was
like a commercial like it was a song
right whatever we we don't care like and
I think I speak for everyone just let me
know do I speak for everyone you speak
from like I didn't care but I was then
surprised by
how decent it looked
Paramount plus is like a good streaming
service like they don't put out crap you
know yeah I'm sure it'll be good but
like genuinely who's been asking for
this it's like you've all been asking
who
you know they could find a tweet that
says anything I know they can find a
tweet that says anything yeah
but there are like actually things
people are waiting for you know
and I just don't think this is one of
them not to be like Sonic you know and
it's like if we were waiting like
the clock ran out a long time ago and
they like used when they have that music
video they pretended it was going to be
like some reboot a few years ago they
were all posting like something's coming
they posted the key yeah they used
honestly they used to be the good
surprise they wasted the good surprise
on that mm-hmm
well anyways I'm being optimistic and
I'm so unlike you I know I was I was
really surprised by how the trailer made
me feel okay yeah okay you should watch
it okay
are you ready for our next story no is
it the next story that's brought to you
by Lululemon yes Lululemon shorts were
made to stretch flex and support the
infinite ways of working out giving you
the courage to LEAP into something
totally new and unexpected the hottie
hot short which is the short with a
comfortable range of motion and a
flattering fit are some of our favorites
we love Lululemon it's summertime it's
getting hot we gotta bear our legs would
you say it's summertime in the living's
easy I would say that I would definitely
say that um but I would say it's not so
easy bearing your legs but Lululemon
makes it easy so that hottie hot short
is great the fabric is so um like
cooling it's sweat wicking it feels good
you can carry your Essentials with two
perfectly placed discreet Pockets the
Wonder train short is also a great short
it's the short with supportive stretch
that keeps you dry they're powered by
the everluxe fabric the Wonder Trend
collection manages heat and sweat so you
stay comfortable and focused they've
also got great men's items so the pace
breaker short is a versatile short
that's up to any challenge the ultra
lightweight fabric means that you can
train move and stretch how you want
without the baggage each pair of the
pace breaker shorts is designed to Wick
away moisture sure so all that's left is
your intention Secure Storage means you
can keep things close without feeling
them bounce around if you know what I'm
saying
and the living's easy thanks to
Lululemon and their shorts which make
getting around in the heat so much
easier making that undercarriage nether
region area dry and safe so get into
Lululemon shorts at lululemon.com that's
l-u-l-u lemon.com
lululemon.com today's episode is also
brought to you by one of Jackie's
favorite sponsors Thrive Market
Thrive Market is our go-to for all of
our organic grocery and household
essentials and the convenience of
getting it all quickly shipped to our
doorstep is a huge Time Saver as Thrive
Market members ourselves we save money
on every single grocery order on average
we are saving over 30 percent each time
it's also grocery delivery which is just
everything of the sort tell me about
your recent experience with the Thrive
Market every time I go to your house I
have such delicious things in which to
snack so many good snacks that are
guilt-free because they're made with
better for you ingredients and I love
that like I don't have to troll the
grocery aisles looking at the
ingredients wondering if they're better
for me because I just know everything at
Thrive Market is vetted it's Thrive
Market approved right if it's Side
Market approved like you don't have to
ask so many questions you just see like
if you're vegan or paleo whatever your
needs are but you can sort on the side
like based on what those things are so
sometimes I'll look for like
um plant-based stuff because I I
wouldn't eat get meat so it's an amazing
way to shop the prices are so much
better than the grocery store and you're
getting better quality foods with better
ingredients and for me like I'm
discovering new items like those puffs
so I got that you got from Annie's so
good I didn't even know Andy's made Pops
I had um I discovered something new
yesterday because I got like a frozen
mac and cheese from Amy's which is like
a different one if the Thrive Market
approved and Zach made it for me for
lunch yesterday
when you joined Thrive Market you're
also helping a family in need with their
one for one membership matching program
so you join and they give join in on the
savings with Thrive market today and get
30 off your first order plus a free 60
gift go to thriveamarket.com the toast
for 30 off your first order plus a free
sixty dollar gift that's
t-h-r-i-v-e market.com slash the toast
thrivemarket.com the toast thank you
charity Lou and welcome Jack Dio our
next story Little Love news literally
Kevin Love and Kate box shared the first
photo of their newborn baby
the Miami Heat star who welcomed his
first child with Sports Illustrated
swimsuit model Kate Bach on June 10th
shared the first photo of the couple's
newborn baby over the holiday weekend he
was pictured holding their bundle of joy
on his chest while at home in Miami
Florida and then she reposted the photo
saying mine
um I follow Kate Bach and his whole
pregnant I mean she didn't post her
pregnancy but the whole thing escaped me
apparently same a month ago she showed
off her bump at an event opening I
missed it and then she shows up on
Instagram like with a baby yeah and I
genuinely never been so shocked shame
because it's not like we're invested we
talked about their wedding he got
married at the New York Public Library
we talked about their wedding at length
like we were obsessed I follow her on
Instagram how did literally how do we
miss this I do not know plus she gave
birth right before game five I didn't
know he was on the heat and that he was
in the finals the Cavaliers I thought no
he's on the heat oh oh now okay then
they won no they didn't oh the Nuggets
won right
so beyond my expertise no I'm pretty
sure the Nuggets won
how do we not know this who wants I just
feel like it wasn't made like big news I
know the Nuggets kind of like does sound
familiar
I feel like because
the Nuggets one it wasn't big news
because like they're not like fancy like
a fancy famous team yeah
I I just feel like like I don't care you
know no I know I feel like if it was the
Heat and it was Kevin Love like she also
would have she posted like a Roundup
yesterday about like how these big life
moments were happening at the same time
and she would have said like they won
yeah yeah but she didn't but I saw a
picture of like him holding a trophy
that's why I thought he won
just like
what's it called like who won the NBA
championship NBA Finals yeah that's what
I just said nuggets okay okay they're
not gets one congratulations happy for
the Nuggets both chicken and plant-based
crazy that that's a name of a basketball
team such a good point nuggets yeah
and like a nugget I feel like nug is
like what people call pot is it and
Denver is like like a pot State
I don't know let's Google why are they
called the Nuggets because
I don't think I'm wrong in that like
that pot is referred to like when it
comes in like a little closer you might
be right but the team was named so long
ago like right nuggets refer to the 19th
century mining boom in Colorado when
people Rush the area hoping to make
their fortunes by panning for gold and
silver nuggets I kind of love that I was
kind of like thinking I know I didn't
say it oh shut up so you knew that but
you just chose to withhold it it's just
like it crossed my mind it was like
something about gold so sure like gold
nuggets sure sure but I didn't say it
sure yeah no I knew that I knew it too
I like knew it but I didn't want to
share it because like I was like didn't
want to be embarrassed by how smart I
was you could hear a pot Theory no but I
look I was just that was just a cover
because like I really knew that it was
about the gold
well you learned something new every day
did you see those memes the only reason
I know is he first Nuggets because I saw
those memes that it's like you're saying
that you're watching like heat nuggets
like it sounds like you're microwaving
that's funny I didn't see one piece of
content from the NBA Finals like I don't
even know stopped being La in New York
yeah like once the Knicks got out which
was very early on like it wasn't very
early it was like
first round or Instagram
um who'd beat them
heat heat and they ended up winning and
they ended up winning no they didn't
[Laughter]
the way like I don't care you know it's
so amazing yeah yeah I just you know
good game yeah but do you ever watch
like every time I watch a basketball
game like when they sing the national
anthem like it is always atrocious
I feel like they're trying to recreate
like the Fergie moment for themselves
and they refuse to have who are you
referring to I just and it's not even uh
celebrities like that it was like
Miranda it could be like a local you
know yeah star I love a local star I
hope to be one one day always bad at the
end in like basketball well whenever I
go
two sporting events like the trade-off
is like fine I'll go but we have to make
it for the national anthem because it's
like my favorite part yeah um and
there's something about like being in
the arena when everyone like takes their
hats off and chance like no it's always
good it's always moving but I'm just
saying like every time I watch Like a
football
national anthem like it's solid it's
definitely a dream of mine to sing it I
you should go for a basketball one
because the bar is obviously have
standards who are the land of the
that was literally so good I feel like
you could sing at like a Rangers game
like New York Rangers yeah and now
[Music]
Brave consider that my audition
so good weave like a few times over the
years like no one ever followed up with
us like kicked around the idea of like
it was a very minor league stuff you
know I have attorney and I like you know
you throw out the first pitch I throw
the first pitch and Claudia sings the
national anthem and like it's a Dream
It's a dream even though like in
actuality like if the offer came across
my desk I would be quaking like I would
might I might even turn it down I'd be
so nervous you would rise today I would
rise to the occasion but I'd need like a
few weeks because I'd have to start
doing like my vocal lessons again yeah
no but you would be amazing
can use you just need to like get
through it you don't need to be amazing
you just need to be good and you just
need to not over sing it yeah no I
wouldn't try and do like as I was
singing before I was going to do like
the Whitney Houston
brave but now I would keep it just so it
sounded good I would [__] it up you have
to if you're not Whitney Houston you
have to keep it simple like rockets
it that's like the hardest part and I
just killed it and I'm sitting down but
you also got to start at a lowercase
bursting in air that was different they
will take that gave proof through the
night that our flag was still there
that was good no you guys someone who
works I know one of them [__] works
for sports then I could do the Fergie
Spangled honestly I could see how she
got so carried away like
and now yeah yeah yeah
like I could see it the song like takes
over
hey
I'm seriously like I have to go to the
hospital I'm not okay
I'm flag [__]
you can't just point at me like
oh my God there's a bug
do it again that actually has someone
react if there was an actual bug on me
I'm so glad we got that on camera I'm so
glad that now you guys and I wasn't just
being a [__] at the top of the show
like she scares so easily oh my God too
easily I'm really not okay I need help
but continue with your singing in your
sweater
oh my sweater yeah
[Music]
wave
or the land of the free
and the home
of
the little flat
faith it's just such a beautiful song
like I would do it I would put respect
on it like I love that song did you wear
that sweater probably you could wear
this whole outfit honestly there are so
many baseball games are we doing with
the stories oh we're running out of time
so I'll just let you know that Ty got
running out of time you have to pee no
oh we're not running out of time sorry
are you okay Tyga and Avril Lavigne
broke up
um who cares right that's your fit and
final story but what I wanted to say is
there's so many baseball games
especially in a season we're about to be
in baseball season if any of you work
for the Mets or the Yankees you guys
like I'm sorry I'm gonna put it out
there because we gotta get turn to sing
the national anthem like that was an
amazing audition and honestly like some
of you guys get the worst [__]
national anthem singers and it's rude
and disrespectful to the country right
it's not patriotic
look at turdy proud American you know
what I am proud American
oh Jose
I love that song it's like my go-to
shower song it's so good it's really
like a stunning song I know everybody
like thinks their Anthem is beautiful
and like I think are really beautiful
yeah I guess I don't know any others hot
Tikvah oh actually I do know how Tech by
the one of Israel that's really like
it's too beautiful how does it start
cool no seriously I'm gonna cry
[Music]
let's see on Sophia
oh Lord
[Music]
inshallah
that's a gorgeous one all right I'll fly
to Israel and do national anthem there
like maybe what do they play over there
soccer 100 football maybe they were
suspecting in Israel yeah that was a
beautiful audition Canada has a really
nice national anthem I don't know that
one and I'm pretty sure that um is it
God Save the Queen yeah it's the British
one yeah what are the lyrics
God Save the Queen
yeah I think that's how it goes no it's
like
oh it's remember from our video with
when we were the Royal oh yeah
remember we also have Hail to the Chief
in this country we have a lot of
ancillary songs America the Beautiful
that's really what about gorgeous song
This Land is Your lamb obsessed Beyond
wait um speaking of Hail to the Chief
over the weekend I watched two movies
that I'd never seen that are like
Classics that everybody's like you've
never fade at the first is Father of the
Bride and I love Nancy Myers and I know
that's like her kind of debuting film
it's stunk it literally stunk it up see
like I love Steve Martin I never found
someone so annoying in my life horrible
then I watched um
the first daughter
is that with Katie Holmes yeah and it's
like she's dressed she's the first
daughter of the country like her dad's
the president the pink dress yeah lucky
charm has been secured
um also terrible but like in a good way
in a good way yeah yeah yeah but
everybody said
um
that there's another movie that's
exactly the same plot like the first
daughter goes on the d-com with no no
that's my date with the president's
daughter no there's like another one
called I for chasing Liberty oh yeah
with Mandy Moore and they say it's so
much better so that's what I'm gonna
watch this week okay great I watched
Father of the Bride recently for the
first time like a few years ago and I
agree like it didn't do anything for me
I watched it while I was on fiance like
it was bad planning my wedding it wasn't
Nancy Meyer's energy like it wasn't even
beautiful no look it stunk yeah
I agree
um okay so I guess we're just scooting
past the fit story yeah yeah Avril and
tiger broke up who cares and I can't
really read the timer that's why I keep
an eye on the timer don't worry sorry
turdy I was worried for you you're like
Panic today no no I just I thought I saw
I thought it was way further than it was
we're good you thought you saw a bug and
then you thought you saw an American
flag okay let's do deer toasters Our
advice segment which I'm so excited to
announce
um there's now more than one way to
submit
isn't that exciting it is exciting so of
course as always you can email dear
toasters gmail.com but now we're kind of
like entering our Tech girl era we have
a new website which is so exciting and I
don't know it what is it toast podcast
the toastpodcast.com the
toastpodcast.com where you can just
learn more about the toast you know
whatever it has to toast Essentials
essential place but you can now there's
also like a little box you can submit if
you scroll down to the website it says
Dear toaster cement and you could just
write in there as opposed to whipping
out your email and it's all Anonymous so
I just feel like that was worth
mentioning all right dear toasters our
weekly advice segment where we do our
best to help toasters in need are you
ready I'm ready hey Jackson Claude love
you girlies so much thanks for always
being a bright spot in my life I'm
writing in because I need advice I've
been dating my boyfriend for six years
now we met in college and we are moving
in together this winter after college
we've always lived close enough in the
city that I never needed a drawer for
any of my stuff at his place however I
recently asked to leave a pack of
contacts and a toothbrush in one of his
drawers in his room and he flipped out
immediately said no said that the
toothbrush was gross even though it was
brand new and that the contacts grossed
him out I tried to reason with him but
he said he would never ever let me leave
them in his room and I can't and I can
just leave them in my car or in my
backpack so I don't forget them if I
need them is this normal behavior this
makes absolutely no sense to me and it
honestly just like hurts my feelings
XOXO a toaster okay that's [__] weird
no by the way it's literally one of the
rudest things for sure but it's not
worth like writing off six years of a
relationship so you just have to
actually disagree I have a few things to
say like maybe he's weird weirdly about
like toothbrushes and contacts because
those are like personal effects like I
would I would see if he has the same
reaction to oh can I see them leave a
t-shirt or a book or something like see
if if it's just about like he doesn't
want your stuff around also with these
things it's generally better not to ask
permission like you just start to
infringe in general I guess but after
six years and you still have to infringe
I feel like this is the biggest red flag
of all time like six years but there
were some college Years which aren't
like I'm even in college you like been a
twin bed like you get I feel like
boyfriend and girlfriends who like are
after like are closer than more normal
couples oh yeah that's not a serious of
a relationship I'm sorry this is such a
red flag like you can't leave a
toothbrush it's not good but I would
give it a few more chances like I don't
know try with things that aren't so um
your feelings like are like what if he's
a germaphobe you know so he'd rather
kiss him I've seen like the way snitch
leaves her contacts around and there's
always like a puddle of saline like I
agree contacts are disgusting and a
toothbrush like do you have a little cap
for it like I'm sorry no no I'm not
saying I agree with him I'm just trying
to understand where he's coming from and
let's try it with some personal effects
that are less germy now if he's so
Jeremy he'd rather you not brush your
teeth right
what were you doing before
or bring like a little cosmetic case and
just like put it under his saying yeah
with all of those things in there I'm
just gonna like give him the benefit
without that he's like a little
germaphobic that's nice I'm feeling like
this is the biggest red flag I've ever
seen like your your boyfriend won't let
you leave a toothbrush at his apartment
you've been together for six years
when you put it like that like there's
something else going on
yeah that's why I want you to try other
things because it's like does he have
other girls over and he doesn't want
someone to see your stuff but also
you're six years in a relationship like
I would hope that you don't have to play
games like that like can you sit him
down be like what the [__] is your
problem
I know but when you're trying to like
enter a new stage of relationship and
for them it would be like you know
leaving things
moving in together like sometimes you've
gotta like
take the back that's right they are
moving in together this winter right
so question mark
um there's something I miss here I'm
serious
I would I would just give it a little
try a few more ways is what I would say
before you give up on six years
what's another two days you know keep
yeah but I'm just wanna let you know
like I'm offended for you and this is a
red flag and I feel like there's
something else going on and I just want
to say that in case like someone else
does end up going on and I was right you
know you know you very well might be
right and it's nice of you you're being
so optimistic today
what's wrong with you and maybe I'm just
so excited about your book yeah and it's
just like even just seeing it there just
buoys me yeah no like a secret project
reveal can heart you know soften even
the hardest of girls it's so true it's
so true and I totally forgot that your
toasters is brought to you by
masterclass I apologize
um master class is everything I took a
master I've taken many Master Class most
recently I took Kris Jenner's and I
found it to be extremely like apropos
for what we do I love the concept of
Master Class I love their membership and
I think masterclass is just the best
also a great gift for somebody I've
given master class as a gift it was so
well received and it was so personal
because there was so many um subjects in
the category that this person is
interested in which was like acting
filmmaking directing like Martin
Scorsese there like it was such the
perfect gift and I'd taken master
classes before and I've learned so much
so if you don't know what masterclass is
it's basically the place where you can
learn from the best to become your best
and you can do it anytime anywhere and
at your own pace so their annual
memberships start at ten dollars a month
and you're basically getting unlimited
access to every instructor thousands of
online lessons exclusive content
insights and so much more there are over
180 classes to pick from everything from
you know Bob Iger our favorite guy my
favorite guy to Kris Jenner Sarah
Blakely Sarah Blakely I believe Gordon
Ramsay they've got Malcolm Gladwell
Steve Martin we were just talking about
him
um Esther perel Mariah Carey no I feel
like the chef ones I haven't done those
yet I'm gonna make exact dude I'm gonna
give them that as a gift belated
Father's Day learn how to cook and make
me a sandwich they have new classes
being added every month and you're
basically going to find practical
takeaways that you can apply to your
life and at work if you run a business
you can use masterclass to even help
your team gain new skills in as little
as 10 minutes either on your phone
computer Tablet Smart TV or even audio
mode get unlimited access to every class
and right now the toast listeners can
get 15 off when you go to
masterclass.com toast that's
masterclass.com toast for 15 off an
annual membership which is already
really affordable plus our code
masterclass.com
t-o-a-s-t all right sorry now back to
the task at hand helping toasters in
need
all right oh this one's interesting
hello ladies love you you make my day I
feel like one of the sisters let's get
into it my fiance proposed to me about
three months ago it was perfect perfect
day perfect surprise the exact ring I
wanted Flash Forward a few months and I
find an email on his Gmail that he
bought my diamond online from a
lab-grown diamond supplier I immediately
confront him and he lied to me he told
me it was real keeping in mind he's been
telling me it's real from the engagement
mentioning that it cost him a lot of
money it's not like he's struggling by
the way he's extremely well off finally
though he came clean and told me that it
was lab grown and that he wanted to
replace it but he got it in the first
place to save some money for our wedding
and a house we will have to pay for most
of our wedding ourselves what do I do I
feel so upset that he lied to me and
made me feel like this ring was real and
super expensive on the other hand I feel
Vain and snobby that I would only want a
real diamond and that he should buy me
one and help us pay for the wedding he
says he'll bring me to the jeweler and
get me a real diamond and he's so sorry
but I just feel icky about the whole
thing I love this man and I want to
marry him but I do feel betrayed help a
sister out it's the lie like of course
if you had what if he never liked told
you it was real as opposed to lab Gordon
when you did find out you went to him
and he never lied about and he was just
up front like you could deal with the
facts as they were and decide if you
wanted to have a real diamond or put the
money towards the wedding when that's
totally like either choice is totally
your call and totally fine it's that he
lied and kind of like gaslighted you
yeah multiple times multiple
unconfronted even when confronted like
that to me would be is a huge issue and
I just want to say like wanting a real
diamond versus a lab grown diamond is
not like an unreasonable thing to ask
for I think everybody Some people prefer
moist tonight like diamonds are more
personal like to have a preference is
not a bad thing
um but to be lied to that you got your
preference is like like an unethical
thing to do yes and then when asked to
double down I'm like it's like you know
it's different to like Lie by Omission
yeah than to like straight oh she didn't
ask so yeah right right so you're
allowed to be upset I think you should
get the ring that you want especially
because it seems like money's not a
factory or she said he's well off and
she didn't bring up cost like right it
just sounds like however much you spend
more on the ring like we'll be taken out
of your wedding budget but yeah and that
should would have been a decision that
like you should have gotten to make you
know yeah because if he had set you down
and said like listen I'll get you what
you want but like that's taking budget
out so do you care more about the ring
like these are the conversations you
have in a time when you're spending a
lot of money on weddings and houses and
rings so I don't know I just feel like
he totally left you out of the
conversation and like lit you up and
told you what you got was real and it
wasn't like to be lied to was just never
a good feeling yeah so where did she go
from here I think you should like really
explain like why like and it's hard to
explain why you're why you're feeling
this way without sounding shallow
because men are so dumb that he'll just
be like the ring you wanted you're mad
it really doesn't have to do with like
the quality of diamond it has to do with
the lie no you lied to my face you're
capable of lying to my face we're trying
to start a life together and that can
never happen again yeah so I think I
really needs to explain to him in like a
dumbed down way because I don't think
most men like have the like will
understand like he'll just be she wanted
a diamond like he's so dumb yeah um but
if you explain it to him in like a
really common rational way how you got
to this like how why why what he did was
hurtful having nothing to do with the
actual quality of the diamond hopefully
you'll be able to get through to him but
there's really no telling
yeah
I'm sorry like that sucks it does you
should like look at your pit yeah you
should look down in your ring and like
be like if you're worried about her lab
grown versus real diamond I'm worried
that like her fiance lied to her about
something like no but the ring is a
representation of the lie and so when
you look at it you think about like the
lie and like but he said he could take
her to the jewelry store and get what
she wants yeah but she'll still think
about the LIE yeah no it's a pit it's a
pit he gave you a pit and that's not
cool no especially during a time like
being engaged is already full of so many
pits you know budgets family it's
supposed to be a happy time no but it's
a time that's that's filled with pets
yeah that's the biggest lie yeah that
they sell to women
that like being engaged is the happiest
time of your life it's literally the
worst being engaged is really bad
getting married is fabulous and being
married is wonderful I can't recommend
it comes with its own you know set of
challenges bag of Tarts just like
everything does just like everything but
it's but it's not like overwhelmingly
negative It's a Wonderful state of being
yeah
um wishing you the best I don't know if
we really helped but
I think we just validated how she's
feeling right also let her know it's not
like the end of the world yeah that's a
good relationship like he [__] up okay
but like he has to really understands he
gets to know and learn grow and learn
and do better
do better all right our third and final
this is the one I was talking about at
the beginning of the show okay let's go
hey Jackson Claude I'm a loyal mom fan
who never misses an episode here's my
dilemma dilemma dilemma that so was my
daughter is 27 and she lives with her
fiance we are very codependent on each
other we need to talk on the phone
FaceTime or hang out every every day
okay she's my best friend my daughter my
soul mate we are inseparable I adore my
son-in-law and I don't want him to feel
like he's marrying us both his own mom
is super close to her to her mother and
they talk every day too do you think
it's weird should I not should we not be
so up each other's asses he doesn't
complain about it but I would never want
to be that overbearing mother-in-law I
only want them to be happy as any Jewish
mother would love you both thank you for
your input so she's done nothing wrong
but she's like feeling she's worried she
must hear how we talk about you know
other people's situations yeah and be
very worried that she's gonna become
that okay no not at all you sound too
self-aware to ever become the villain no
also it's like this relationship between
you and your daughter is completely
neutral like she wants to talk to you
every day she you guys are each other's
soul mates you're not being overbearing
by just like being so present in her
life and being her best friend no but
she's worried that like the son-in-law
like finds her annoying and like won't
say anything he hasn't said anything
but until there's a problem like
no and it's like you're not no that it
it doesn't exist also the relationship
between wives and their mothers is very
different yeah do you know what I mean
knowing if you're not meddling in their
relationship it's as if she's FaceTiming
her best friend every day like what the
the
fiance is gonna be like mad about that
like talk to your friends yeah unless
you start like coming over unannounced
that's where [__] gets like face timing
every day with like mean mother-in-law
energy and like talking [__] about him
but it sounds like you really like him
you just like love your daughter so much
and you're worried you guys spend too
much time together but like I think
that's a beautiful thing it sounds
harmless at this point totally I think
as long as you like don't start becoming
like the toxic mother-in-law With No
Boundaries like showing up unannounced
you know doing things once they have
kids like that they don't approve of you
know there's so many toxic mother-in-law
things like as long as you sound so
self-aware like this isn't even an issue
yet and you're writing to us I'm not
worried about you in the slightest you
honestly sound like a dream
mother-in-law yeah no you're good the
relationship that you have with your
daughter is so amazing beautiful like no
problems here closeness isn't a crime no
but things do get sticky you know with
in-laws and stuff but I think you're
totally fine yeah and it sounds like
Everyone likes each other yeah it sounds
like an honestly a gorgeous family to be
marrying into you sound like a queen
yeah all good but let us know if
anything gets dicey with the other
mother-in-law you know
it'll happen it always does they're
engaged they're engaged right they
haven't even had the wedding yet right
so things are about to get really tough
really tough God speed to you my toaster
friend that's our show that's the toast
before you head out for the day before
we head out for the day make sure to
head to thecamperinthecounselor.com
click on the link in Jackie's bio it'll
be in my stories it'll be the toast
stories you'll be able to find it you
can also just search on Amazon or search
on Google Target the camper the
counselor by Jackie ashrae support women
authors this book will change your life
and that's our show would you forget
anything it is just a wonderful
children's book and it's honestly it's
fun for The Mamas it's so fun to read it
is like that iambic rhyme is it hits
different it hits every time and I'm
just really excited that it's out there
I've literally been like it's been in
the background like all my pictures that
I'm taking like I actually haven't even
it's probably Easter eggs and like some
of like my Instagram stories um because
it's just literally constantly next to
me because we're always reading it or
just looking at it and I'm so excited to
share it with everyone and I'm so
excited for the sequel the turd and the
turd yeah so stay tuned for that
pre-order link but in the meantime this
one in the meantime this one and then
I'll get to working on this year oh you
haven't even started let's just go no I
have to like the idea
and then the let the words fall where
they may fall where they may
thank you guys so much for listening to
the testimony Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories you need
to know everybody Friday on YouTube so
you're watching us on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe give this
video thumbs up this episode was like so
crazy Russell available
video I already castbox all the places
we are hope you guys have an amazing
Wednesday I'm in studio tomorrow with
Bane and it's gonna be fabulous so I'll
see you there bye